juegos históricos porque es la primera
vez que una ciudad repite como sede de
unos juegos de verano los de 2008 y los
de invierno es además la primera vez que
un mismo estadio repite albergando la
ceremonia de apertura y la de clausura
de estos juegos
hablamos como no del estadio nido de
pájaro de beijing de la capital china la
situación de la pandemia llevó a la
organización a cancelar la venta de
entradas para extranjeros y solo se
invitará a unos 150 mil aficionados para
algunas competiciones en el esquí alpino
y de descenso eso sí no habrá público
son los juegos de la nieve artificial no
habrá nieve natural en estas
competiciones tenemos a unos 3.000
atletas de 91 países y veamos ahora cuál
es la representación latinoamericana
vamos en orden alfabético comenzamos con
argentina que tiene seis representantes
bolivia envía dos atletas brasil es la
delegación más grande entre la región
con 11 atletas chile 4 colombia 3 y
ecuador una sara escobar primera mujer
de este país
estas justas de invierno haití tiene
también un representante primera
representación de este país en la
historia de estos juegos méxico cuenta
con cuatro atletas pero con uno y el
territorio de puerto rico con dos
definimos para esta lista a países
latinoamericanos a aquellos que según la
definición más tradicional hablan
derivados del latín es decir el español
el portugués y el francés